and of course no one is talking about
the substantive points of that rally
everyone is just talking about the crowd
sizes so the left is now attacking Trump
for not having a big enough crowd we
were promised a zillion people were
going to show up and then there weren't
as many ironically before the rally the
left was preemptively attacking Trump
for having too many people at the rally
he was gonna have too many people I was
gonna spread coronavirus then there they
were more spaced out there were some
empty seats there making fun of Trump
for having not enough people three
theories of this was there intimidation
outside the rally was it left to
sabotage or was it lack of enthusiasm
for Trump we know that there was left to
sabotage aoc admitted it she said
actually you got rocked by teens on
tick-tock who flooded the Trump campaign
with fake ticket reservations and
tricked you into believing a million
people wanted your white supremacist
open-mike to pack an arena during Kovich
a doubt to Zoomers you all make me so
Pratt's she was saying was teenagers who
did all this turns out it wasn't really
teenagers it was older leftist activists
here's one woman admitting as aoc did
that she she was pushing for all of this
a woman named Mary Jo lope who does not
exactly look like a teen or a Zoomer but
here's the tick-tock she made if you've
been paying attention to the news you
know the Donald Trump is planning on
holding his first political rally post
quarantine on June 19th in Tulsa
Oklahoma now if you talk that's a big
deal I want you to google two phrases
June teeth and black Wall Street you'll
find out why people are really upset
about this so why it's a slap in the
face to the black community somebody on
another tick-tock Post commented that he
was offering two free tickets on his
campaign website to go to this rally so
I wasn't investigated it it's two free
tickets per cell phone number because
when you register you have to give them
your cell phone number they send you a
code you put the code in and your
tickets are reserved for you so this
probably means having worked on a
political campaign this past fall it
probably means that I'll start getting
text messages from his campaign all I
have to do to get rid of those is text
stop that's all you have to do once you
tip stop they have to stop texting you
that's the law they have to leave you
alone so I recommend that all of those
of us that want to see this 19 thousand
seat auditorium barely filled or
completely empty go reserve tickets now
and leave him standing there alone on
the stage what do you say okay so she
admits it AOC admits that there was some
sabotage going on there were some
protesters out there or in timid
protestors intimidating Trump supporters
who wanted to come in I think there's
also a campaign issue the campaign could
have handled this better we know that
the left pulls these sort of tactics
they do this to every speech that I give
on campus they always reserved a lot
more seats and then they either don't
show up or they show up and they leave
early that's why we have an and a wait
list line outside to immediately fill in
the seats I was actually giving a speech
about six or eight months ago defending
George Washington at George Washington
University in Washington DC you might
say that I saw this coming this toppling
of the Washington statues so I was
giving a defense of Washington and at a
certain point about five ten minutes in
whole group of leftists left and we
immediately filled the seats back in
campaigns you have seen that coming and
the campaign should not have caved to
the mob on moving the date you remember
the initially the Trump rally was
supposed to be on June 19th
Juneteenth now the most important
holiday in all of America Juneteenth is
the day that Republicans told the slaves
in Texas that they were free and this is
somehow become a political issue for
Democrats I don't know how that how they
managed to do that so they said the
Trump campaign has to move the rally
can't be on June 19th June 10th and the
Trump campaign acquiesced to this this
shouldn't have done that first of all it
created some confusion over when the
rally was and it dispirited people
because they caved to the leftist mob
needlessly and counterproductive Lee so
I think the campaign should learn some
lessons from this be better prepared
next time look this was the first rally
set in three months right since the
lockdowns that's fine the important
thing is we need to get back out there
and see some more rallies
[Music]
you
[Music]